it's one of the world's holiest sites
and recent weeks have once again seen a
rise in tensions as the holy month of
ramadan coincided with a jewish holiday
of passover
the number of jewish religious
ultra-nationalist groups entering the
site has increased
some are part of the temple mount
movement whose members call for the
right to pray on the site
the incursions are protected by israeli
forces and seen by palestinians as a
major provocation what would take place
in small groups and respectfully is now
being done in large larger groups
and more provocative more defiant and
more humiliating for the muslim
worshipers there and this is what it's
all about the al-aqsa mosque compound or
temple mount as it's known to jews where
certain hours are allocated during the
week where non-muslims can enter but
under a long-standing agreement between
israel and jordan which is the custodian
of the site only muslims can pray there
however over the years there's been an
increase in the number of jewish
religious ultra nationalists entering
the site calling for the right to prayer
and actively attempting prayers there
and that scene is a gradual erosion of
the long agreed status quo
according to the islamic wakuf the
jordanian religious trust that runs the
site the number of jewish religious
ultranationalists who accessed the site
in the past year was the highest so far
many try to pray and are sometimes
removed by israeli police this is
the weaponization of faith and religious
pyromania in recent years
that status quo has begun to erode
and israeli policies under netanyahu
became
i would say more permissive
there was
turning a blind eye to quiet prayer and
then more
demonstrative prayer rami works for the
islamic worker and says he has witnessed
the same thing
he was injured by israeli police while
documenting what happens in the compound
the police are turning a blind eye to
these prayers these groups call for
invasion with huge numbers they say the
site's theirs and they must demolish the
dome of the rock and build their temple
instead this is how they think and this
is what's causing the escalation and
triggering the conflict
rafael is a member of the temple mount
movement who we met earlier this year in
an illegal outpost in the occupied west
bank so now i'm not allowed to go to
jerusalem at the time he was considered
a security risk by israel's internal
security services the shin bet and
banned from entering jerusalem's old
city maybe the police don't like what i
do and maybe it provokes the police and
the country because we want to go to the
temple man we want to
that it will be able just to walk there
freely that we won't be escorted by
policemen that we could pray
whenever we want and where we want on
the temple mount
the growing temple mount movement is a
concern to many palestinians and muslims
across the islamic world who say that
al-aqsa is a red line
consecutive israeli governments have
maintained they have no intention of
changing the situation and israel's
foreign minister yeah lapid on sunday
reiterated israel's commitment to the
status quo that only muslims pray and
non-muslims visit
events at the al-aqsa mosque compound
can be linked to triggering the second
intifada and also the most recent gaza
war last year
nothing has the same ability to mobilize
major protests and anger here at what's
long been a volatile and emotionally
charged religious epicenter stephanie
decker al-jazeera jerusalem